[Música]
qué hace un investigador entre tantos
dólares pero realmente el día del ensayo
me di cuenta del talento que tiene
entonces
porque debe ser invitado
la constante experiencia
desde el premio nobel en 30 minutos
y qué orgullo que debemos sentir todos
los 17
[Música]
hay un investigador
y
pero fue una experiencia maravillosa
y el haber podido
de representantes
pero menos
desarrolla 25 años
en nuestra universidad católica de
santiago
pero volviendo
donde se utilizaban agua potabilizada
para el control de la sigatoka negra una
enfermedad producida con los hombros
y que en todos los países del mundo se
utilizan químicos para controlar la
enfermedad en nuestro país usamos
alrededor de 5 millones de litros de
publicidad a la que se aplica sobre la
lo cual constituye un verdadero horror
y un verdadero nivel de contaminación
tan alto que una de las principales
responsables del crecimiento de la
colombia y centroamérica
el proyecto ya trascendió
nuestro ambiente
hace dos meses por la universidad de
carbón
en desarrollo
[Música]
para desarrollar también un proyecto
para mí
y luego
pero sin la colombia francia zanetti
y el caribe el cuadro
[Música]
y
proviene del 2019
importante ningún producto que se ha
desarrollado de manera combinada con
químicos
solo para que tengan una idea
la tolerancia que permite
la luna
yo
muy bien
países
a cuatrocientas para ti
lo cual constituye un verdadero honor
es por eso que tendrán alternativa
agroecológica nuestro proyecto de
investigación
fue nominado por qué
y ya no es posible seguir caminando
que la tierra dando la marina
[Música]
en situaciones de espera también le dice
miren
ya no sólo por la contaminación
y es por eso que hago
a seguir desarrollando este tipo de
agricultura
ya mencionadas de químicos sino la
a base de productos orgánicos la
agricultura sostenible desarrollar la
metodología agroecológica
también mucha vinculación
[Música]
pero antes de cómo este proyecto fue
nominado
yo soy miembro de la sociedad española y
europea
[Música]
en nuestra universidad y estando
universidad de alcalá
también investigadores cubanos donde yo
hice mi doctorado
queremos que
así congreso de noviembre del 2000
ha iniciado la aplicación
y estamos ya que ese congreso
después de meditarlo también
fui a donde él
y había cuidado del pueblo
para la vida
y
[Música]
y muy importante así que queremos
proponerlo para que sea nominada para
ver menores dijeron
es lógica que estamos perdidos recuerda
mis nervios que nunca
de esta manera
y esa pasión del gobierno yo le decía
[Música]
estación
bueno ya
[Música]
la habitación
bueno
salió por todos los días todo lo que
están realmente
una grande
indicador
con un perfil bajo
[Música]
la gente me llama para
fotografía y responder experiencia
el día
pero salvo una foto mía en la primera
página
y los temas que decían el exterminador
del haciéndolo
entonces me llaman media
y se lleva
universidad esquina donde había un señor
dónde
a delgado y digo que es también una
empresa
[Música]
y si no media gente
y felicitaciones
y bueno ese tipo de cosas es ahora
generalmente
[Música]
sabe que no es necesario seguir
hemos seguido investigando por qué
la gente que lo son
[Música]
una sustancia grasa lo trópico que tiene
una característica
y ya a nivel mundial usamos mucho para
controlar las enfermedades
y de mínimos
esta metodología de varios trabajos con
razón
[Música]
españa-méxico alemán y francés han
comenzado a desarrollar también
investigación la capacidad de estos
campos virus y bacterias es fabulosa y
además de ellos la particularidad
de la e
sólo utilizar a cumplir esos nombres los
transforma de estado su nombre y eso le
da mayor capacidad
[Música]
el día
y cuando sea una de las primeras
personas que llamamos al presidente
no no
si estamos unidos a decir
menor
los millones
esta sea la oportunidad para aprender es
como bien estos momentos
algo así
que iba a división a través de sí
ahora
y no hay nadie
la versión cuarto del hambre
la mente
d
[Música]
de árboles
es muy
y de nuestros vecinos pero luego
colombia
entre 1.5 del pib dedicada a la
explicación
los países desarrollados invierten en
308 conscientemente
lo que genera la investigación
también las asociaciones por ejemplo
articultores
también tenemos un problema terrible la
posición del cogollo es
no
y realmente me
nos dio mucha pena ver estos productores
de palma
tenemos problemas
prácticamente una tierra
lineal por lo que tienes
sin embargo al ver la necesidad que
tengo
en los productores de banano
aceptar
para lograr controlar
las mil hectáreas de palma africana
pero también se desarrollan
para mí no era
también tienen algo por delante
el uso de los ojos para el control de la
principal enfermedad
realmente el uso de la policía
provoca serios
disminución en el rendimiento del ganado
y con el uso de los otros se ha logrado
ya a nivel
hemos logrado aislar de loco de la
orilla y el misterioso y encantador
[Música]
es
en él
como la banana al amor
d
la siguiente organizando
y eso ha provocado que muchos los
productores bananeros
por tres años en todos los países
cuando nosotros
[Música]
nos bloqueamos porque al final todos
estos congresos
[Música]
le interesaba
después de la acción
me llamaron los mismos que realizaron de
solo
en el próximo congreso que ha venido
[Música]
y demás
la conferencia es enorme
problema
esta es la metodología
[Música]
realmente para nosotros quienes hacemos
diversidad
es tarde
el haber podido participar con esta
experiencia con este proyecto de
investigación
esto va a sentir para todo el punto
donde se sentirá a tener una alternativa
agroecológica para no contaminar más el
planeta
[Aplausos]